welcome to this video yeah this is a new
video about one of my over the board
classical time control tournament games
this um game was played just a couple of
days ago in the Dutch League
the yeah the
top league in the Netherlands the May
star cluster Master League Master Class
something like that would be it's a
translation yeah we played um with my
team we played them the Dutch team
champion and my opponent was freezo
nibor naibo is a player in his mid-40s
has been um
strong GM for a long time his top rating
was above 2600 to 630 or something like
that nowadays it's about
2550. so I was a slight Underdog in this
game
and I had the black pieces again well
the third black game in a row in the
Netherlands and it's quite funny that in
all uh three games the position after 12
moves was identical
so let's have a look
nibor is an E4 player and he's a very
dangerous attacking player and very good
tactician so
I didn't mind to play relatively close
position so let's see what happened he
plays the Royal Pass and I play with A6
it's all very classical and well known
and well I don't play The Marshall
attack so I went to D6
C3 now this is um done to
get a square for the oops for the bishop
castles and now age three this is the
absolute main position of the Roy Lopez
the closed Roy maybe nowadays you could
argue that the Berlin is the main line
of the rui but this here the position
after move 9983 will always be one of
them
yeah main points of action in the rui
because it is um
pretty much principled play for both
sides once A6 has been played on move
three yeah so here I play Knight A5 the
chigo Rin this is the oldest line
available here for black
and um still maybe the main line in
terms of the pure number of games played
um on top level people nowadays very
often
tend to play Knight B8 the Breyer system
or Bishop B7 the side Sev yeah but I
play Knight A5 Bishop C2 C5 this is one
Merit of the move Knight A5 with Knight
E5 you actually gain a Tempo on the
bishop because it wants to yeah Retreat
to C2 don't want to trade the valuable
Spanish Bishop
and with this Temple gained black has
the time to push this C5 move the
triggering is actually the only line
available to Black on move 9 that make
sure that the C Pawn is used immediately
and all other lines it can happen that
um the C5 move is delayed for quite a
while or not made all together
yeah D4 is played
and queen C7 yeah this is a played
really tons of times already Knight bd2
and Knight C6 yeah Knight C6 here is not
a main line that is however one of the
oldest lines available for black and the
line that I have played numerous times
in tournament chess
um I had a video on my channel
um
this game was played I think in
September where I had a game against
Otto Pipers in the Dutch League where he
traded
the other main move is D5 and well this
is the total Main Line D takes C5 is a
is a side variation d 5 was played in
round two by
um a strong International Master to one
book his uh 2500 player and this was
this was round um round two
I didn't do a video on this game because
frankly nothing much happened
um we got a very close position that is
in fact quite comparable to what I get
in the game against sniper and he
offered a relatively quick draw like
after 20 23 moves or something and uh
well I didn't object to a draw against
them a somewhat stronger player it was
okay for the team so this was pretty
much a non-game it wasn't worth
presenting in a video Yeah D5 here
played by nabo and I went Knight to d8
this looks very strange yeah this Knight
to d8 move but it has a point black is
um aiming for a defensive setup
um this line he has um part of my
repertoire for quite a long time and it
is part of my repertoire because well
the first book that I bought on the Rulo
passes black featured this line done by
the Romanian Grand Master and
theoretician Michael marine or Michael
Marin as yasa saravan
pronounces it I always think this sounds
like some DJ
um well whatever this is the line that
he recommended and well to be honest I
didn't like it that much but well it was
in the book so I have had a look at it
and I started to play it and I had good
results so I stuck with that and I'm
playing the line to that day I never
lost with it in tournament chess so
let's see a form
Rook B8 B4 yeah this is a very good
approach for white he wants to gain
space on the queen side and with a Pawn
on B4
it looks at those two squares the Knight
on d8 has no future on the queen side
putting it on B7 would be really uh
foolish in a way because you're only
looking at squares that are controlled
this was one of the main mistakes that
that worker unseeker made in his game
against karpov in in these 1970
is it 1974 I featured this game on my
channel in the middle game
section or was the chess giant section
if you search for once again in my
channel you will find the game
um yeah I went C4 closing the queen side
Knight F1
the typical regrouping and now Knight to
E8 yeah this is the idea that black has
with the setup what he wants to do is he
wants to put his Knights on G7 and F7
after G6 F6 one night here one night
here Bishop on D7 so you have a setup on
the seventh rank
um and I always kind of like that setup
it is a very defensive setup but it is a
very very solid and tough to break down
I have won games with this um quite
often surprisingly with this somewhat
passive looking setup
plays an interesting plan and it is um
it should be mentioned that he played
all this instantly so it seemed a lot
like preparation to me and this is
a bit surprising because in the Dutch
League I mean if he would have known
that he played me as wide this is clear
yeah that that he would prepare for that
because I had played this line before he
plays E4 this all pieces together nicely
but in the Dutch League
um you don't have a fixed board order
yeah the board order is changed in each
match and can be altered you can play
Boards nine in one occasion or board two
so we played this on board too and I
will plays one of the top boards anyway
but I could also appear on more broad
four or five seven whatever
um and actually it is my third game in a
row with black which made it very
unlikely that I would appear on move two
with black again as you normally want to
alternate colors it was a yeah slightly
glitch that I had black again uh it
didn't mind it that much but it made it
very hard for him to anticipate play me
but he still seemed to have prepared
against me somehow yeah Knight 3 H2
actually I think that this is a very
good move what he's doing is the
following Bishop D7 that that's clear I
need to do that
and now we played A5
the point of Knight to H2S is F4 by the
way we will see this in short order he
played A5 however and he played it
quickly and that's an interesting moment
really this A5 move because during the
game my initial reaction was that
this is a bad move actually I was
thinking it is a bad move because I
thought
normally white should benefit from
opening the a file He's got potential
points of entry on A7 his Rook is on the
a far so I rather expected something
like that to happen he could play Rook
A7 which okay it doesn't lead too much I
can't trade the Rooks but um still I
thought he should keep the option open
of keeping on B5 or just take on B5 I
thought A5 wasn't really any good but
during the game I sort of reconsidered
because
it does two things that I didn't really
appreciate at first
playing A5
um make sure that there's no trades
happening on the queen side at all in my
game against Chuan book we had all Rooks
traded on the A4 which was possible
because he really played a very
imprecise move order and with all Rooks
gone lots of White's potential is also
gone so with A5 he makes sure that there
are no traits on the queen side
it does the second thing sometimes black
has the idea Bishop d8 to B6 to exchange
the bishop okay well that's not possible
anymore theoretically speaking you can
do this kind of
snake-like maneuver but this takes ages
and will probably not ever be completed
so it's an interesting way to make sure
that black is not trading stuff
and sort of relieving himself because he
has got less space
also in some cases it might be an idea
that A6 is now a fixed Pawn yeah some
some maneuver like like here G4 C8
taking here I know it is a deep end game
idea but it is in the position
um yeah during the game I thought okay
he can do that it's no mistake
um it has advantages to exchange on B5
in other yeah other aspects are also an
advantage to having a
um well let's start again if you take on
B5 there are other points that are in
White's favor so I wasn't sure at first
but now I think it's yeah he can do both
actually we would see one point
that is different
after this F4 I played F6 now
um yeah F6 it looks very passive I know
but black is not in a position after the
move F4 that definitely will happen
um after this move to to use the E5
Square only with pieces it's it's not
possible unfortunately something like
Bishop to E5 Knight to D7 or something
it's not going to work I have to play
with F6 and block the whole thing so I
played F6 right away
F4 and now I took I think black should
take really because if you don't do that
you can start with a move like Knight F7
but then white has the additional option
to play F5 after which admittedly it is
very closed but also very simple for
white to play he will get in G5
eventually and uh well this is very
passive
well not that the game is very active
but it's better to have the E5 post one
point however after the capture on F4 is
if we go back what I did I took here one
point for white however is something
that we would see right away I'm
regrouping my knight
he goes here this is a big point of this
F4 move with F4
and the trade against the e-pawn why it
has relinquished the E5 Square black has
a knight there which is nice
but the Knight by the way is not
attacking anything that's very important
it's a nicely positioned piece that
however is not having a clear Target but
white on the other hand has gained
something the default Square for his
Knight
it's very important so white has a
clear compensation in the center let's
say for black Central last night in his
night on D4 this is by the way also a
difference of Pawns being traded on B5
or not with the pawn traded instead of
advanced to A5 B5 actually would be
attacked by the Knight and black has to
use one piece all the time to keep B5
safely protected this is also something
that made me believe that A5 is not so
good but well we see in the game it has
some Merit yeah it's uh I think it's
okay it's an interesting idea that
neighbor platium
um also during the game again I realized
when you look at those moves they they
are very um natural I have Brook F1
rookie eight
put this here I realized that um it is
very difficult for black to really do
anything yeah yeah this uh A5 move it uh
yeah it sort of kills the queen side as
a Battleground I mean even as a ground
for exchanges so it's all on the king
side and on the king side I have
absolutely no idea what I can do I
cannot really play F5 as this square is
controlled tons of times
um something like G5 I mean it has no
idea and it's totally ridiculous they're
giving up F5 so I can can push no pawns
um it just can only sit in the wait here
what I can do the only active idea very
long term would be to try to exchange
these Heaven Bishop via H6 which in fact
later I get to play but um I realized
that really this is very very passive
yeah with the a file open in comparison
and I could think about moves like Rook
A8 yeah just trading stuff or Bishop d8
B6 as I mentioned but this is not really
on here so A5 is an interesting strategy
really
yeah Bishop d8 is what I played I
intended Knight F7 to G5
and uh well to be honest um I didn't
really know what to do
besides well sitting and waiting Rook
ae1 Knight F7
Bishop H2 and Knight G5 yeah I'm
actually threatening something
he went
back 91.
yeah mission accomplished I got to G5
and attacked his Pawn but what am I
doing now
it's really it's really not much fun
yeah you're just sitting there and await
proceedings
um after a while I actually decided to
just go back here and put it again on E5
I know it looks poor but well you cannot
really do something active anyway
rookie 2 Knight E5 and he went back to
E3
yeah and and here I decided that the
only plan that I have really is to try
to exchange this bishop via H6 so
something
like that and I thought okay well this
is the only idea then I should try to
get it in Bishop E7
G4 yeah G4 is a fairly normal move in
this kind of position you look at F5
even more so that it can never be played
and um there's also the idea H4 and G5
F7 yeah clearing the way for the bishop
Rook G2 and now I went to C8 yeah
keeping an additional eye on G4 so that
H4
and now it's not really on
it's also okay really yeah he went to
Queen E2 protecting G4 once more and I
went King h8 again angling for this
bishop trade
Rook F to F2 is slowly improving
Queen D2
Queen D2 yeah Queen D2 this is a a
little trappy move yeah
um
black could consider H5 yeah trying to
nibble at this Pawn but then white has
this
oops
and queen H6 mate it's the big threat
so why just wins with Knight takes E4
yellow H5 is a big mistake
I didn't fall for that I went 98 yeah
again according to this idea
Bishop to D1 yeah actually here around
here I think he's slightly
he slightly lets me into the game yeah
um
instead I think Bishop F4 was an IDM
just um already uh yeah putting it on F4
to prevent Bishop H6 he sort of ignored
the idea I went to f8
and now H4 yeah
the problem is or problem is a little
bit too much but if you want to prevent
this you run into Knight D3 and all of a
sudden black is totally fine
so H1
not this but H4
yeah and um
yeah it went
Rook E7 yeah I want Knight F7 Bishop H6
if if possible and this is not a bad
Square anyway I'm threatening 93 now as
E4 is is a weak Pawn
played Rook F1 getting out of 93 and now
I went Bishop H6
yeah the position is is still good for
white but um it is um it is very
difficult to play and we approach time
control now the whole thing uh costs
quite this costs quite some time even if
it was lots of shuffling but you still
have to look at all the various ideas
yeah G5 he played
and I took on G5 and it seems that
Bishop G7 was was better but okay here
white could have gotten a pretty
substantial advantage
with um yeah
slightly untypical move and this is
Bishop takes E5 I know that I didn't
really consider this move at all
it looks very weird to to take only five
here to be totally honest the problem is
that if black now recaptures with the
pawn
there is Knight C6
and this gives white a tremendous game
yeah if we oops that was that was a
wrong button I'm sorry for that let me
put this on the board
yeah and here as mentioned he could have
taken
could have taken on E5
um what is Rook takes E5 didn't I
analyze that
yeah Rook takes E5 is probably
yeah that's probably the same thing
right
yeah well this is this is the problem
here
I can now take on G5
you can take here and at the NTM
white has a tremendous position and you
will get E5
ah it's not fun it's not fun
but Bishop takes E5 wasn't considered by
by both of us and he just recaptured
with the
with the pawn
I went to G7
and um yes it's interesting again Bishop
takes E5 is quite a good move but it's
um it's a difficult move to consider it
looks really wrong
to give up the good Bishop on H2 but it
would have been interesting if you would
have taken him
I have to recapture obviously and
nothing really nothing really looks good
this is um not something that you want
to play but while Bishop takes Knight G4
is also a big problem if you capture
this will lead to Invasion on E6
and well if you retweet him then this is
coming
play a terribly passive position and
white has a tremendous attack if I need
to give up this it's not going to end
well
so it's just um really bad
yeah um and um
yeah again he didn't do that he played
instead of this
he played the move I think Rook F4 right
yeah I need to move Rook F4
and after that I definitely am back in
the game
93 and Rook H4 this was his idea
Rook f8 taking the f file
Bishop E2 and Knight E5 back the Knight
was hanging on D3
he now went Bishop G3 yeah this
also a sensible move intending Rook H2
yeah and here I'm um I'm making a
mistake really
um with the right continuation I think I
would have been really okay I played
Rook e to F7 and I played this because I
really um yeah I wrongly evaluated what
what is happening
the better move here was King to G8 just
um prophylactically moving out of the H
file if um
Wyatt tries to um go now
with um yeah Rook G2 H2 I can actually
drop back to h8 and just cover H7 within
decent game that's really not bad
or he can try to um
yeah play in a very direct way you can
take only five but after that I am also
um quite okay takes Knight G4
Bishop G7 rocket G2 H2
and Rook F to F7 covering F7 tactically
my Bishop takes D4 check
this position is quite okay um the
computer is giving it is about equal
and one point is that this is a slightly
weak Pawn let me get rid of this this is
a slightly weak Pawn those two
and uh well my position has got some
points yeah I've got the bishop pair and
uh if I'm not getting checkmated quickly
here I'm definitely not in in bad shape
but I didn't do that
I played something else
I didn't play King G8 but I played Rook
e to F7
wanting to use the f file yeah of course
I saw what's happening I saw this move
and now um I thought that H5 would be
okay but it turns out that this isn't
the case
um I was still able to put up some very
serious resistance with the moves queen
d8 or King G8 they both um probably lead
to the same position
King G8 Rook takes and queen d8
trying to get G5 and it's not so easy
for him to keep it I mean okay he can he
can try yeah after Queen d8 what was my
main move analysis I think Knight to D1
yep
and then Knight D3 is possible intending
Knight F4 and with the Knight coming to
F4 the situation is not at all that
clear of course I'm also threatening
this with a check winning The Rook on H7
this is not given as a huge Advantage by
the comp so I could have I could have
and should have played that
what I did was wrong I played as
mentioned I played the move
age five and my problem was that I was
very um satisfied with this kind of
thing yeah here black is in really good
shape yeah all of a sudden my pieces get
active and can even argue black is
probably better here
so this wasn't the problem it was clear
that if there is a problem it is
something with the peace sacrifice on H5
um however we both failed to see the
best continuation now for White and the
best continuation again is this pretty
non-standard in my book what white can
do and what wins the game instantly
um to be honest what he played also wins
but
the
the strongest is Bishop takes E5
surprisingly the reason is that after
Bishop takes the only move that really
makes sense white can actually sacrifice
him
quite quite surprising I mean I didn't
consider the sacrifice at this
particular moment let me look at the
line again I don't want to
show you something wrong yeah this is an
amazing sacrifice I mean it looks
totally normal but
why does even giving up this so that now
he's a whole Rook down yeah if I take it
but it's still a winning position here
if black takes it
this will lead to a little little
checkmate
it's uh yeah it's quite remarkable
um what black can try to do is he can
play King to G8
and not um yeah getting checkmated
instantly but it also is a winning
position yeah if you give it to the
engine white um will win this win in
this attack
the easiest actually to take yeah and I
have no squares for this Rook yeah this
is a direct mate it's it's a disaster
really
um the the main reason why this is
difficult for a human is that the move
Bishop takes E5 really is not very
um it's not a very obvious move and
after this you even give up the exchange
on H2 from yeah complete for a rook
deficit and still you win so that wasn't
um at all easy to see what he is playing
is actually a move that I saw relatively
quickly after I went H5 but somehow I
didn't see it before
he played the move Queen to D1
not this one oops
what's happening to me
um where is the main move in this
Jungle of lines Queen to D1
yeah this is what he played and now the
idea is to take here twice then with the
queen on H5
and well as soon as I saw the move I
recognized that I'm in huge trouble yeah
I went to King j8 that's a relatively
best defense and he sacrificed the point
is that now the queen can take on H5 and
this is going to enter end in trouble
yeah it took took a while to to figure
out proceedings but it really is um it
is a lost cause if I take it
Queen takes yeah Queen H7 is is the
threat and what are you doing now to
defend there is really no defense yeah
you cannot move the bishop here even to
um to a decent Square
so white um is definitely winning
um after this
white can even do this and give up more
material
something like that
it's um ultimately
winning for white yeah despite the Rook
a rook deficit
it's an amazingly strong attack
yeah in the game as mentioned I went
with the queen to d8
trying to get G5 back Bishop takes here
on G6 very strong very strong stuff
yeah I took on G5 now which definitely
loses Knight takes G6 however also loses
but um yeah it was very strong
performance Now by neighbor this part of
the game he's really playing this um
very convincingly this and queen H5
it's not ending well black will do get
checkmated probably although it's not so
easy to uh to prove unless you probably
invest hours if I take on age for him
at first I thought that even G6 would
win but Bishop D4 in fact wins for black
it's not necessary however white will
just uh retake on H4 and have a
fantastic attacking position for example
if we look at this queen takes and there
is this thread black is a rook up here
yeah it's a rook for two Pawns but I
really don't think you can defend this
it seems the only line that is at least
continuing the whole thing
is to capture and play Rook G7
after which
this
is leading to an excellent attacking
game something like this for example is
uh is really really ugly
you know here here white has a fantastic
compensation he's got uh three pawns for
the piece and the big attack I don't
think that black will survive this
yeah it's um a really strong attacking
performance
yeah in the game as mentioned I am after
Bishop takes G6 where is it actually
here Bishop G6 I took on G5 simply
because I thought the other line is lost
so I have to go for that this is uh
probably even more more lost in a way
but it is um
yeah it is um
a lost course Bishop G6 is coming
2 pm
went back
now if you do a count I'm an exchange
and a pawn down and there is no
compensation here the only reason why I
continued was that he only had um we're
playing here with 90 minutes for 40
moves plus increment of 30 seconds and
then after 40 moves uh 30 minutes per
play extra and at this time he was down
on a couple of seconds at one point but
not really troubled yeah but I continued
because of the little time and well as
long as you have a knight you don't
resign this is all term
motor or some some Blitz players
and um yeah I'm not really a very late
resigner I resigned when I think it's
it's it's it's proper to do so and
actually here I did so a very nice game
by naibo I really had no active idea the
whole game and now I can tell you one
story that I couldn't tell before the
game because it
kind of would have spoiled the result a
little bit or at least my acting
abilities would have been challenged
um this line is um something that I want
to wanted to abandon from my repertoire
this kind of yeah this kind of line here
with 98 I wanted to abandon from a
repertoire for quite a while because I'm
perfectly aware that it is not a
particularly great line black is just
very passive and one advantage of it is
in Blitz chess you can play moves very
quickly and get a Time advantage and
whatnot that's all nice but look at the
position it's so passive white has a
good game if he plays it well and um I
really um I really um yeah don't like
the position at all and actually I
always said that I will the instant uh
as one if I lose one game the the
instant moment that this happens I will
abandon this line forever and yeah this
is the time now so if anybody is
watching this video and they uh intend
to do some prep on this line here you
can skip that part I will never play
this passive setup again is really
really not great I think you can improve
on my play certainly but the kind of um
position type is just unbearable yeah to
look at internally as you're sitting
there and you have no active idea so
it's something that I I wouldn't really
recommend to play
yeah on the other hand an interesting
strategic approach by neighbor I think
in retrospect this A5 move or the idea
to combine F4 with A5 was a good plan
it leads to a wide advantage and a very
one-sided game and um yeah it's
something that can be recommended for
white players if you happen to get this
this line
so it's a good modeling game in a way
for
for those who played the rule of pass on
the white side yeah I hope you enjoyed
this video it wasn't nice to to lose one
of the final games in this year I only
lost three games this year one was in in
January one in May and one now in
December so I had almost half year
non-losing streak not bad
um
I also wanted to mention um to complete
uh the picture I also wanted to mention
that I didn't do uh videos for all of my
tournament games I played uh some games
where I didn't um I didn't make a video
they were all draws so
um and then times uh quite boring
um it was even a game recently where as
black my oppon simply traded everything
it offered a draw and it was kind of
pointless as I even was a rating
Underdog in this um in this matchup but
it had really no chess content so I will
absolutely post every game that is is
interesting to post but I won't do I
don't know 15 move draws that really
don't um interest anybody I think so
don't wonder if there are games missing
if you might look at my feeder card or
something and say okay why is this guy
not posting the other games they were
really not much to talk about okay I
hope you enjoyed this video despite me
getting a thorough beating
okay thanks for watching